want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and get the seven best
lessons from elon musk oprah winfrey
jeff bezos and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one find meaning with oprah
winfrey how do i define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich lesson
number two have the right framework with
elon musk the physics training is a very
good training
where
it's a good framework for reasoning
where you're trained to
think about first principles and reason
from there
and that means boiling things down to
the most fundamental truths and then
connecting those truths in a way
to to try to understand
how reality is
because you know physics has this
problem where they're trying to figure
out things that are totally
counterintuitive
and so they had to have a framework for
for getting there like quantum mechanics
is incredibly counterintuitive
but it's true
um and so you had so physics developed a
framework for for figuring out
uh things that aren't obvious and that's
why i think it's it's it's it's a lot of
advice but it's it's it's the right
framework lesson number three play hard
work hard with richard branson life is
short life should be fun and it should
be fun not you know it should be if if
the the chairman of the company is
having fun you know if you go to a party
and you know if i let my hair down and
i'm the first to be thrown in the
swimming pool and uh and i'm not just
sitting standing in the corner of the
room sipping sherry or something then
everybody will have a laugh and
everybody have it fun you know if your
gemini company be the first to dance on
the table you know just get everybody
else up dancing on the table and make
sure the party's you know the party's a
laugh so
uh you know so play hard and uh play
hard work hard and then uh and you know
follow certain principles in life you
know be you know you know love people
make make sure you make a positive
difference in this world while you're on
it also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four build work life
harmony with jeff bezos this work life
harmony thing is what i try to teach
young employees actually and senior
executives at amazon too but especially
the people coming i get we're asked
about work-life balance all the time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because it um
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and
and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody paying attention to
you want to have you never want to be
that guy and we all know we all have a
co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all of
the energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy so
you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step
lesson number five always keep learning
with bill gates certainly during the
time i was at harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do
uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was
unbelievable that became more obvious
during the three-year period i was here
uh but my dad had been a lawyer
i thought of mathematics you know like
doing well in the putnam that was the
coolest thing uh and the computer
software
i didn't think those people were as
smart as the math people so it's like
well am i going to go into the easy
field uh or this really hard field but
uh
anyway math uh was fantastic when i
finally picked
and decided to go go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age uh 19
uh to about
40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or how mitochondria work
i was pretty
monomaniacal and when i was able to ask
steve this is the year 2000 c balmer
uh
he
he mistakenly graduated uh but then he
started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine but then
he started at stanford business school
and he was in his first year and i
thought this is perfect i'll get him to
drop out of stanford business school uh
so in a certain sense he is a dropout uh
uh and he was very key to the success of
microsoft i mean
uh
he knew a lot of things but during that
period i didn't get to do much at
harvard
you know i took all these courses
because it was just so amazing that
people were interested in talking about
them and uh
i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed up
for i finally started to work on those
so i was in hillel the minute would open
to the minute it would close during
reading period trying to catch up on on
that other set of courses so people say
i'm a dropout which is literally true
but
because i like college courses the
online college courses there's a company
called the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
in at least four or five courses a year
in a sense i like
uh going to college more than anyone
so
i've sort of made sure my job certainly
post microsoft
that i get to spend my time meeting with
scientists
learning new things you know seeing what
the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on
uh
those very very hard problems lesson
number six be your own hero with grant
cardone when you kind of look back now
what would you say are the traits that
you know when you do look back that you
needed to kind of turn your life around
you you need to know you need to you
need to under you need to be honest with
yourself right like like i am i am
brutally
honest with
and maybe why the people in in the uk
like me
like i just tell the truth to myself
okay and the fact that whether other
people can handle it or not it's up to
them
money's important
if you're broke you're selfish
if you're broken you're even more
selfish
anybody can make it
no matter what your troubles are how you
what side what side of town or city the
city you were born in what class you
were born into if you went out and
you're not and you're not going to make
excuses about how to get out
um
you can do it if i can do it anybody can
do it like today we i have two billion
dollars worth of real estate today
one deal at a time putting one deal like
that is an amazing
feat for anyone but for someone that
came from where i'm at
no credit when i was 25
nobody's taught me really how to do any
of this stuff
but once you make a decision you got to
make the decision you got to make a
decision not to be comfortable you got
to make a decision and say look i want
to have
so much
that i can take care of not just myself
and my family my two kids and my wife i
can take care of communities
and that's what i've always wanted i
always wanted to be a hero dude
i'd watch batman superman
wonder woman you you you know i read
those cartoon books and i'm like i want
to be the hero
and um and i think it's important that
people
understand they can be the hero and
lesson number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is put in
the time with mark cuban you almost have
to have that drop like in other words
you can't fake it you can't like pretend
that you want to read about ted turner
and okay i'll skip one movie
your soul yeah i mean you can fake it
too you make it in a lot of areas
particularly if you're working for
somebody else but at the end of the day
um
if you're going to be
created something you've got to make the
effort to be great at something um
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day you know
when i got started in in you know after
i got i i got it i was a bartender when
i first came to dallas got into the pc
industry got fired started my own
company but
there i learned early on that there was
always something new and most people
didn't put in the time to learn it it's
like now with artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something i've always
enjoyed so that i've been fortunate at
that now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you i believe that
the
primary success factor for amazon.com
has been an obsession over the customer
and a focus on customer service this is
clearly important in any business but
especially important online and the
reason for this is that word of mouth is
incredibly powerful online
if you make a customer unhappy on the
internet they won't tell five friends
they will tell 5 000 friends on usnet
news groups and list serves and so on
likewise of course if you can make a
customer happy by meeting or exceeding
their expectations they can also tell
five thousand people and therefore you
know be evangelists for you they can use
the internet as a megaphone
so it's very important to do the things
that you actually are going to claim to
do and
what this means obviously is the balance
of power has shifted away from the
merchant and toward the consumer which
is a great thing i think for everybody
involved it's even great for the
merchant as long as the merchant
realizes it recently you said that the
biggest mistake you've made
professionally
was that
microsoft should have had the android
technology why was that the biggest
mistake
well
when you're in a field and we were in
the field of doing operating systems for
personal computers we knew the mobile
phone would be
very
popular and so we were doing what was
called windows mobile
we missed being the dominant mobile
operating system by a very tiny amount
we were distracted during ironic trust
trial we didn't assign the best people
to do the work so it's the the biggest
mistake i made in terms of something
that was clearly within our skill set we
were clearly the company that that
should have achieved that
and we didn't we allowed this motorola
design win and therefore the software
momentum
to go to android and so it became the
dominant non-apple
mobile phone operating system globally i
had a job until i could figure out what
it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and um i i'd gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color and i was the wrong
size and i was the wrong you know i had
lots of problems and they were trying to
take me off the air
and um
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000.
that'd be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was mrs chancellor's
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the carvel ice cream men
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do
all these years have been misplaced in
news because i couldn't relate to news i
was a news reporter and i'd be out on
the stories and i'd be crying with the
people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was august 14th 1978
and that was the beginning of fulfilling
the calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time because i just
exhausted all the time because i hated
it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and because
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's going to play a black woman
between two thousand dollars a year
you're never gonna make make that kind
of money again you better save half of
it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay everybody wants to be an
anchor woman at the time that was like
supposedly a big deal being an anchor
woman so i thought okay i won't i'll
just stay with this until i can figure
out what is the best thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do i felt like i
needed to be able to talk and at the
time the only thing that was available
was um
was uh like good morning america or the
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one bryant
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show
he said that to me
and um
interestingly enough he called me last
week because somebody else mentions it
to say he never said it but he did say
it and i said to him you know what if
you're ever told that you never forget
it if somebody ever says to you if
you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
you you're fueled by the energy of your
work so i know that i'm doing exactly
what i'm supposed to be doing at this
time
i also know that what the the show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing what drives
you what what is it that when you wake
up in the morning do you see a problem
and you want to solve it
uh
i i think the the thing that drives me
is that i want to be able to think about
the future
and
feel good about that
so
that uh you know we're doing what we can
to
have the future be be as good as
possible
to be inspired by what is likely to
happen
and to look forward to the next day
um
so
that's that's what really really drives
me is is trying to figure out uh how do
we how to make sure that things are
great and
i'm going to be so and
that's
the underlying principle
behind tesla and spacex
is that
i think it's it's pretty important that
we accelerate the transition to
uh sustainable generation
and consumption of energy
it's it's inevitable but it's it matters
if we have if it happens sooner or later
and then spacex is about
helping make life multi-planetary
and doing what we can to
continue the the dream of apollo
and
ultimately
make contribution to life becoming
multi-planetary now let's pretend that
you're just about to graduate from
college right what's the advice
um you don't need the perfect job
you know um
part of the problem is you probably have
a hundred thousand dollars of debt right
um
and you gotta pay for all that
um
and that's really [ __ ] up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um
my advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just
enormous is
you paid all that money to learn
now here's your chance to get paid to
learn and you don't need the perfect job
you need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge added to
your foundation because
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22.
hell no there's just no chance that the
30 year old or even the 25 year old is
going to look back at the 21 or 22 year
old you and say oh that dude had it all
together knew exactly what was up right
he's gonna look back and go beer pump
what were you thinking you know and so
it
don't expect to have all the answers and
don't try to get the perfect job go out
there and get paid to have different
experiences and it's okay to jump from
job to job if it's not the right job you
are getting paid to learn flip it and
then use that to build your knowledge
and learn more about yourself learn how
to learn in business and see where it
can take you any young person
even before they start their career
is to really think about their choices
because
i find young people and i i when i was
young i had i made this mistake too
you can get
very fixed
on your gifts so everybody has gifts you
know you you have gifts and you have
things that you didn't get gifted maybe
you're extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life it's your choices
that construct your life not your gifts
you can celebrate your gifts be proud of
them be happy of them actually don't be
proud of them
be celebratory of them but you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them you
can only be proud of the things you earn
and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my gifts i was always
good at school school was always easy
for me and i was always proud that i was
a great student i got a's in all my
classes i was good at math all of that
and i thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to
use my gifts in certain ways to
challenge myself to
do things that i didn't think i could do
to put myself in uncomfortable
situations we all get i would say to a
young person
you can choose
a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life of service and adventure which one
of those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of it is
always being ahead of the game rather
than getting behind the game it's saving
a little no matter how you do it i mean
i delivered papers i worked at pennies i
sold golf balls i had a pinball machine
round i did a lot of things that enabled
me to accumulate about ten thousand
dollars by the time i got out of school
uh
ten thousand doesn't go as far now as it
did then but it having anything so that
you're ahead of the game and not getting
behind the game
is enormously important i mean just
you know if you're going to run 100
100 yard dash against a bunch of people
in life
if you can figure it out so that when
the gun goes off you're 10 or 15 yards
ahead
instead of 10 or 15 yards behind it's
going to make an enormous difference in
how that race comes out so
having having some net
resources
doesn't make much difference whether
they're in stocks or bonds in my view
but
and not having debt
when that gun goes off when you get out
of school
uh is a huge plus over being behind the
game and
uh
you know
it may come from delivering a paper out
in the morning it may come from
part-time work someplace but
but put aside a few dollars for yourself
but uh
so that
when the time comes and you enter
the enter the workforce uh you're ahead
of the game and not behind and then once
you get there don't get behind by buying
a whole lot of things that you figure
you're going to pay for some day while
you're paying 20 interest in between how
would you describe each phase of the
evolution of oracle and how would you uh
sort of describe running each of those
phases you got to do this quick
i gotta well i mean and clearly being a
part of a company with four people and
being a part of a company and by the way
that's we're 85 000 now post post merger
with sun you know uh on 100 uh we think
about sun's got about 20 000 employees
and you know uh twenty five thousand
employees we're about a hundred five
thousand
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh what has not
changed is i ran engineering
at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to and is always reported directly to me
is engineering not sales not marketing
not support and not consulting not
services at various points in time lots
of other people have run run those
operations the back office accounting
order management all of these things the
only thing that i've done consistently
during those 32 years is run engineering
because i believe basically that once
you reach the you will you know you win
as as we say at oracle it's amazing our
good products seem to do very well and
our bad products
not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage is developing
the right products recruiting the right
engineers and having the right
organization wherever you're at in life
right now at this very moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them i don't think it matters if they
have a faith or no faith i don't think
about any of that i think everyone
universally has a knowing or a truth
inside uh and i think most people never
learn how to get still and hear it and
most people if they do get still and
hear it they're to know right now live
while they're listening to your knee
are they in the right
job they're supposed to be in
or
is there is are they are they playing it
small
are they in the right relationship
or are they in it and dimming their own
light because of fear
that maybe they'll be alone we all have
a knowing right
and you know what i'll say about the
idea of
giving up leveling up all of that
i think it's so important that um you
know in that moment where i had the and
again let me just say there's so much i
did wrong and i share all that stuff too
one of the things i did right was when i
had this this gut feeling as i'm sitting
there with this skin problem this gut
feeling oh you're supposed to figure out
how to how to create a beauty company
even though i knew nobody in the beauty
industry had no connections had very
little money because television news
does not pay very well um
i had that knowing right when i look
back at this journey of three years of
constant rejection down to under a
thousand dollars in our bank account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these beauty retailers
that i put on a pedestal and i couldn't
understand why they were telling me i
wasn't the right fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you you feel
like you're doing something you're
supposed to be doing but like for me
there was no proof around me that my
idea was right there was no traction in
my business there was nobody saying yeah
that's a great idea let me buy your
product and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe in the
brand and everything around me was
saying you're wrong
and the easiest thing in life is to
confuse that
with the truth i like the people who
never give up
and i've been proved this for so many
years i've seen so many great leaders in
the world in many many fields
those people are always optimistic they
don't complain
ah you know because of this because that
no that
they think they completely complain uh
i was not that smart i did not think
about that clearly so i had to need to
change
so if you find a people who always
complain the others because you needs
success don't hire him don't work him
with him one of the things that seal
said to me and it's in in the book and
one thing that people have said that
really resonated with them he would say
that when you're when your mind is
telling you you're done
you're really only 40
done
and he had a motto if it doesn't suck we
don't do it and that was his way of
every day
forcing us to get uncomfortable to
figure out what our baseline was and and
what our you know
what our comfort level was and just you
know turning it upside down
the 40 rule maybe it's give or take a
little but look at a marathon most
people hit the wall at a marathon at
mile
anywhere from 16 to 20
and you know
99 of the people in this country that
run marathons finish
and they all predominantly all of them
go through this hit the wall so where
does that extra 50 or 60 percent or
whatever the numbers come from i mean
it's their brain saying i'm done i don't
want to continue
but they're will saying you know what
let me get to the finish line so we all
have that will
it's just a matter of how do we apply it
to
not just the once a year marathon but to
our daily lives and make it you know
apply to
a variety of things you don't need 150
iq to do what i do thank god you know
you don't need 140 you know 135 you may
need 115 or something like that and and
but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball you have to you have to swing
at pictures that you you don't even
necessarily
like particularly after the count gets
to two strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 it
says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but
it's a marvelous game to be in because
there are no called strikes and you can
simply wait for that one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price where you like the people running
the business and then you swing and you
only need a few swings in your lifetime
do you remember how much your first
server cost you said oh yeah no 85
dollars 85.
yeah no and i remember that because um
that was the gating factor for us
launching new schools i i mean we had
this philosophy from the very beginning
that we didn't want to be this project
it wasn't even a company at the very
beginning but we didn't want to be
burning a lot of money right we weren't
planning on raising a lot of money we
didn't want to be one of these things
that raised a bunch of money and you
know was losing a bunch of money and
then decided that we'd somehow pull it
through at the end and um so you know so
85 dollars for the first server put ads
on the site and the the ads at the
beginning were uh we just were running
some kind of ad network and you remember
what the first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um
this was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get an ad network so that way we can we
can make more money but then whenever we
had more money we rented another 85 a
month server and we kind of went from
there and um i don't know just it's just
an interesting way of seeing never spent
money you didn't have in the beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars is
you could get yeah and i mean it was
actually good because i mean you know
sometimes it's really nice to have the
time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and um you know the fact that we could
kind of go college by college and and
kind of optimize the service and make it
more efficient and offer new features
but make sure that they worked um i
think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who've never built
a company before we've never built any
large scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it um and you know
people these days like to talk about how
these services grow super quickly then
facebook did grow quickly but i think it
took a year for us to get a million
users and we thought that that was
incredibly fast but um and and i think
it is but
it wasn't as quick as a lot of things
grow today and i think actually having
that time to bake it was really valuable
i think you should be doing something
you're passionate about so the question
is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford which will go to stanford law
school
um possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was it is it just uh
you know and i was on this super tracked
for myself i ended up at a big law firm
in new york
in my eighth grade junior high school
yearbook one of my friends wrote and i
know you're going to get into stanford
in four years i went to stanford four
years later went to stanford law school
ended up at a big law firm in uh in new
york where on the outside everybody
wanted to get in on the inside everybody
wanted to get out
when i left after uh seven months and
three days
um
one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz which you know
all you had to do was really just go out
the front door but um but so much of um
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win
and um that um and when you compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at if you take lots of sat test prep
classes you'll get a better score on the
s.a.t
and when you compete you get better at
beating people on the narrow things you
need to beat them on but um but you
often it often comes at this very high
price of of losing sight of what's uh
what's truly valuable and important and
meaningful
which is
well i think passion there's well
there's sort of all sorts of other
they're all sorts of things that that
could be that but but i think
um i think it often the the i think it
often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's obviously financial version
where you get to be have a monopoly like
business
there's a the meaningful version i think
is always counter factual where if you
weren't doing this
would you know it's great to be working
on problems where if you weren't working
on them nobody else would do them you
know if you're working at the fourth
online pet food company the 10th in film
solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would um you know
if you're working at uh
at something where
it's the only thing of its kind in the
world that's very meaningful if we
weren't if we and it could be for-profit
non-profit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled
i think that's the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful
when 2008 happened i had nothing to do
with 2008 i had two businesses and i was
starting to buy real estate and i was
not buying the real estate to cause the
problem in this country any of you
remember when lehman collapsed
your business if you were in business
your business probably got hurt
i wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
securities i wasn't doing the no money
down houses
you know i wasn't selling that stuff i
wasn't doing mass development on the
backs of the bank
with bad loans
but
because i lived in america
and i was doing business at the time
i got greatly affected by that my first
two businesses got cut in half and my
real estate was frozen up i owed 52
million dollars to a bank that went
upside down new bank came in they
started making demands on me i ended up
in a lawsuit aren't there a bunch of
lawyers in here yeah i ended up i ended
up in one of these crazy lawsuits where
the guy was going under he had done some
things wrong and he decided to pull me
down with it
it was a frivolous lawsuit that was
costing me 200 grand a month to fund i
had never been involved in a lawsuit in
my career
so that being said um
i looked at that situation and said hey
what did i do wrong here
like i always look
at how am i responsible responsible
able to respond that is the definition
of responsible able to respond
now in my case i was being forced to
respond
it wasn't a lot of able in it
so uh
but the one thing that i walked away
with was i had a baby on the way i just
been married i just got married maybe
three years before that so the marriage
was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage
not really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and i new
baby coming along
i lived in los angeles i lived in a
beautiful house up in the hills
uh overlooking all of l.a and i pretty
much thought my life was great until
2008 happened
now i'm taking a second to get you to to
what i want you to hear i didn't plan on
2008 i didn't think about a lehman
collapse i didn't know
40 million people were going to go
upside down in their homes i did not
know it would affect me i didn't know
one of my industries was the automobile
dealers i was working with automotive
meal dealers around the united states
that was my primary business
i was making a couple million bucks a
year i didn't know
9 000 car dealers would go out of
business
who would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with today
who in their business plan had coved as
part of your business plan
let us know in the chat put put put a no
in the chat if you didn't have a plan
for that yeah
yeah i need to see 316. i need to see
one
one guy in here say oh yeah
i planned on mask
oh yeah i had i had myself going out one
week buying
400 worth of toilet paper
okay
uh
oh yeah in 2020 by the way how many of
you in 2020 january first you're like
this is gonna be the best [ __ ] year
of my life
oh yeah
yeah everybody gave that up on march
23rd the entire nation of america
gave up
surrender 2020.
look the news the media
by april was saying 2020 is over how
many of you heard that [ __ ] i'm
throwing 20 20 away fortune 500
companies 100 companies carnival cruise
lines general motors ford motor company
like mass companies were like i'm done
i'm tapping out
this year's over
wall street every day i'm watching
bloomberg right now wall street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020. let's reboot for 2021 the entire
nation surrendered
your kids aren't going to schools
you didn't plan on that did you
see this is the problem with the concept
i think i saw somewhere in your promo go
big or
go home what's the saying go big or go
home ain't nothing at home folks
there ain't nothing at your house you're
not gonna make your business work at
home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that out and say look i gotta
go big or i got to go bigger because
going home cannot be a choice now and
the whole country went home we've been
quarantined you're going to have 10
million probably 8 to 10 million
bankruptcies by the end of this year the
the other shoe has not dropped yet the
stock market's going crazy the rich are
getting richer and and i don't include
us on this call as the rich the rich
will get richer
okay you why because they think big
they think big they never waste a crisis
and we are in a crisis
and the crisis if you were in trouble
before covid you are in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because people in this country are
satisfied complacent
comfortable these are the enemy so if
you can take anything away from me it's
like look you have you and your wife you
and your husband you and your kids must
give up ideas of comfort or maybe i just
blank out the word doubt
[Laughter]
um
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too so i i thought we you
know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who
who doubted us i was like well i think
you're probably right you know
i mean the number of times uh
that i was told like
uh because i was taking the money i
learned from from paypal and enrolling
into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but
um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon 1.
um
and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people tell me this joke like how do you
make small fortune in the rocket
industry you start with a large one is
the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
so
anyway um and it was it almost came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch and then uh and that wasn't even
enough to save the company we also then
had to win the nasa cargo resupply
contract um so that that came a little
after you know a little bit later or
towards the end of 2008
those are the two key things that that
saved spacex otherwise we would have we
would have you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those those doubters were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately uh
fatah smiled upon us and brought us to
this day it's really important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to give the what's
in it for them very concisely and very
quickly so with with differentiating
yourself i'll use an example i always
say you've got to differentiate you've
got to tell the person or the world why
you're unique and why you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have and then you need to let
them know why that matters to them
so
i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say and then you
know how our underground options they're
not that great you have regular
underwear that leaves a panty line that
you can see or these very thick heavy
duty girdles that are too thick under
your beautiful clothes or your nice
slacks and leave lines on your legs
okay then i've just given them the
options that are dysfunctional and then
i tell them well i've just invented this
product and look what it does it meets
in the middle of the options that are
out there and here's why it's going to
be important to you here's why it's
going to matter you're going to be able
to wear white you're going to be able to
wear cream you're finally going to be
able to wear all the fabrics in your
closet that you don't wear anymore and
you're going to you're going to look
amazing you're gonna have no lines so
then i would give the what's in it for
them but that's just a quick example and
i would always i like to start with the
problem that i'm solving have them just
sort of invest in it with you
and then
why the other options aren't so great
people need to know from you you're the
only one that can do it why you're their
best choice
don't don't assume that they're going to
just try to figure it out people are
busy people are you know we got a lot on
our mind tell me even in an interview
when i'm interviewing people i want them
to say i'm your best candidate and
here's why and be very clear about it so
what are your core values personally and
professionally
uh core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you that's the basis for most
religions but they get sometimes carried
away in rights and rituals but that's
the core value do unto others as you'd
have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success unshared is definitely
failure
in other words when you make it it's not
really just about yourself making it hey
if you make it you know you made it but
along the way one of the great lessons
to learn
is it's not all about you
it's about your ability to be of service
to this planet while you're here and by
saying me me me me look what i did this
is me hey here's my building my name's
on it you know i did this you didn't by
doing something like that it kind of
takes away from how genuine you are and
because people don't like to just listen
to people talk about themselves how
great they are they want to know
incorporate it to make them successful
also or do something a little different
and i think that's very very important
one of the things when i really sit and
think why why am i comfortable taking
risks what is it yeah um where i come
from i was really lucky when i was
growing up my dad used to actually
encourage my brother and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say sarah what
did you fail at this week and if i
didn't have something he would actually
be disappointed and i can vividly
remember coming home and saying dad dad
i tried out for this and i was horrible
and he would high-five me and what i i
didn't realize it's so awesome i didn't
realize it at the time but it was he was
teaching us that failure is is not
trying versus the outcome and so with
spanx and everyone's saying it was such
a bad idea initially and you know i feel
like i i feel much freer to be willing
to
you know fail in the traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the out end
result and the more it's like working a
muscle the more you're willing to risk
something and maybe fail you realize
there's always a really awesome hidden
gift in it
it's either you meet someone new that
brings you to a different place in your
life or you learn something new or
and and so i always was really excited
by what how my life grew by every risk i
took well in my 20s and 30s
i was fanatical about software
um you know i didn't believe in
vacations uh didn't believe in weekends
uh
you know i was focused on software uh
day and night you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left uh
and i knew every line of code
and it you know i enjoyed being a
fanatic uh
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft doing great software and you
know learning from our mistakes and
hiring the best
the best people there are lots of times
especially in the early days uh that
were that were very very difficult i
think i think the most difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its
had its only lost quarter in history and
we've been in business for 20 years of
the 20 years we lost money one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almost we doubled our
sales virtually every year for for ten
years
nine out of ten years ten out of 11
years it was really quite an amazing run
we're the fastest growing company in
history still we still are the fastest
growing company in history over a long
period of time
and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we
would reach a billion dollars in revenue
and we were having serious management
problems all over the place
and
the people who are running the company
the billion dollar company were the same
people that run the company when we were
a 50 million dollar company 120th the
size
and i hadn't had
an incredible sense of loyalty to those
people who'd worked with me to build
oracle
and it was a very painful
realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that
people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those are the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse just entirely
different skill set in running a 50
million dollar company than a billion
dollar company
and uh
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means i had to ask people who i'd
worked with for a decade to leave i had
to fire people
uh
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business asking that yeah
a bunch of people to leave oracle
i had no choice
and if they asked them to leave oracle
or everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh
thousands of people worked at oracle
they deserved the best leadership
we could find
and
my primary my primary responsibility was
to the company and
all of the staff
you know all of our shareholders and all
of our customers
and uh
therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go i have always known
this about celebrity
the real
power of being
somebody that somebody knows and i
really think that the only difference
between being famous and not is that
more people know your name
so the only difference
between understanding that
is understanding that what selma has
done what susan has done what anna has
done rebecca has done what jim has done
what i've done
you too can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself
and giving what you have been given
how will you do that
how will you use your personality
the energy of your personality to serve
that which is your soul's calling
i know this for sure
any life
no matter how fantastic it is how
glorious it seems how much attention you
receive how much square footage you have
any life and every life is enhanced by
the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space
your life gets better when you can find
a way to share it with someone else
so what we've done you can do the real
empowerment comes when every person
leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a decision
maybe that decision is that you will
write a check and support some of the
wonderful organizations you've heard
here today
but the true decision is
how will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given
to serve that which is greater than
yourself
how will you use that to become
truly
authentically empowered
now
it is a beautiful thing to receive an
award and to be on the cover of variety
thank you very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted don't stop
looking for a job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know
that there's not opportunity there
because all it takes is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent whether
it's emailing calling you know setting
up on seminars whatever it may be
however you can connect with people
applying for jobs to wherever however do
it you know every node gets you closer
to a yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity to propel you to where you
look to be
and you know and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when i came out of college way back
when um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know i remember
reading the story i went to indiana
university talking about how the
unemployment rate in northern indiana
was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today and i had to be
mobile right i had to go from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that that i could platform and so as you
look for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
you don't have to get the best job you
don't have to get a perfect job you just
have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an mba
free agent right they might spend one
year or two year at one two years at one
team build their skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking at building your
skills that to prepare yourself for what
comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
one of the great secrets in life
to becoming successful
whether it's in a business
whether it's working with someone or for
someone or in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection because if you're prepared for
a lot of rejection it comes you don't
get turned off you don't get
disappointed like well i'm not going to
do this anymore no one thinks it's a
good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars they slam
them in your face
you must be just as enthusiastic on door
number 101 as door number one and that's
what the real secrets and growing up as
kids in downtown l.a we all knew that we
didn't have a lot we noticed a lot of
things going to turn you down at seven
trying to sell a flower pot on the
street most people said no but it's only
50 cents no no no
sooner a waitress a little restaurant
said only 50 cents that's really great
she bought it from us and we went built
another one why the point of having a
seal live with you this is this book's
called living with a seal 31 days
training with the toughest man on the
planet and i watched a few videos on
this guy he's a freak um but why did you
decide to
to have him live with you when he first
moved in the first he comes into the
house and he has a little knapsack for
30 days if i go away for 30 days i'm
checking two bags yeah he has this
little like huck fin for 30 days all his
clothes and everything and his whole
life in the bag and i said to him his
name is david goggins so if you're
listening and you know him or you want
to google him i said in the book i refer
to him as seal but now you know he's out
there so
he came to the house and i said to him
you know hey
here's your room you know i'll show you
around make yourself at home and you
know my home is your home for the next
30 days and he said no no he said i
don't have a home
and i said no make yourself at home it's
an expression
and he said
i don't operate in expressions wow and
that was sort of like okay let's start
so that was that was kind of our opening
act no settling in no yeah and then we
went down to the uh gym five minutes
into the into our 31 day journey
and um
he said i want to see how many pull-ups
you can do so i said all right so uh i
guess to kind of get a level of like
where i was at and i am not a strong
sure guy so i did maybe eight pull-ups
and then i dropped down and it's all
right wait 30 seconds and do it again do
it again so i waited 30 seconds got back
up on the bar i did like six he said all
right one more time and now like i'm
starting to feel it you know like i
don't think i can even get back up on
the bar and i get i get three but three
like you know kicking getting my chin
over like whatever i could do to get
over the bar
so i said all right what's next he said
what's next is we're going to stay here
till you do 100 more
oh my gosh and i said one at a time
and i'm like come on man like that's
great on paper
but i physically can't
do
a hundred more
and um
that was our start of many lessons that
i learned because i ended up doing it
one at a time
and what he taught me was that so many
of our limitations are self-imposed
you know and we set we set something up
in our brain we program our brain one
way
and that's our limit and until we can
get past that and see what we're really
made of and like get uncomfortable and
experience pain
you can't real you don't really don't
know what you're capable of yeah so that
was a really good good lesson for me and
um every day was a lesson like that i
was paying my way through school and i
was working as a waitress at denny's and
it was a challenging denny's and so what
i mean by that is they had problems
getting pancakes out and people get so
frustrated so it would take an hour
sometimes to get your meal so i would
talk and try to like you know learn the
customer stories yeah i would you know
anything you didn't have to ring up like
the ice cream i would i would offer ice
cream whatever anyways i got fired for
talking too much
yeah yeah from denny's but it was a
blessing to go through right because i
learned a lot too and i was like okay
trying to understand i didn't know at
the time i'd be an entrepreneur later
trying to also make sure i figured out
operations so even when you're sitting
there inside of a kitchen going why is
it taking 45 minutes to get pancakes and
what's the ordering process and the back
end of the operations it's all a gift
like everything we go through can be
that way you have a lot of smart people
but you say there's a difference between
smart and wise
tell us about that yeah
the difference between smart people know
what they want
and why people know what they don't want
so i have a lot of smart people it's
difficult to deal with smart people
very difficult it's easy to deal with
stupid people you know they follow they
go to toilet they go to restaurants
together but smart people it's all
different but what we need a company is
not
it's not a farm my company is a zoo
we have all kinds of
animals
people talk people never talk people
work hard people never work i mean these
are this is this is amazing ecosystem of
the company that make the company very
very powerful and colorful i feel happy
that and a leader is not the proof you
are smarter than the others
a leader's job
is to making sure everybody giving their
smart ideas out
you listen to them
and sometimes you make a stupid decision
because you have to balance
you have to believe in the future it's
not smart to people win
it's the wise people
win
and for the future
so
this is what i believe we need more wise
people
are leaders smart
machine will be always smarter than you
are
but machine can never be wiser
smart people using brain
wise people using heart machines don't
have heart machines only have chips
so this is what i think human beings
should always learn to be wise
to say no
to know what you don't want
that's that's my view you know i think
that uh i think there definitely are
things that one can iterate on but the
the core thing is to have a
great product and then you can always
improve and and iterate on that in all
sorts of ways and i think you know i
think um even in in the tech industry um
uh what's striking is how
um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it in all sorts of all sorts of ways
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
i think that that rarely works um i
think it's always worth asking you know
where you're gonna go with this business
um and so i think we're always focused
on very short time horizons because you
have to you know figure out a way to get
through the next month the next quarter
um you know how do you get some
customers how do you how do you track
but it's it's always worth thinking
ahead you know five to ten years you
know why will this be a really valuable
business in five to ten years and um you
know how's the competitive landscape
going to develop how's technology going
to develop how's the world going to
develop um these are hard questions to
answer but i think um i think i think i
think the the great entrepreneurs that i
know always have some perspective on it
and it might be wrong but it's just this
is what's going to happen and then it's
sort of well reasoned
and and so you have a you have a plan it
and you know it's uh when i when i was
playing chess uh you know in junior high
school one of the early lessons i
learned was a bad plan it's still always
better than no plan at all right and so
you know have a plan you can always
change it but don't don't just pretend
that uh that you have no clue about
what's gonna happen and that everything
about the future is random if you if you
sort of say that everything's random and
out of your control that's that's that's
the way you set yourself up for failure
the hardest thing for me early on
was you know because i i just started
off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and
you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of you have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on on everything from
architecture to product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and
i think it's really
easy when you start
building something to um
to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so you know
most of my mistakes early on in building
the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
you know episode where
where like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
um yahoo tried to buy us and
so they offered a ton of money
and a lot of the people who who i'd
hired at the point they were kind of
experienced technology executives and
this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they they joined and then you know
within you know a year or a few months
like the the company had the opportunity
to exit for this large amount of money
and
you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for
and
in the absence of that
that context then of course it was a
rational thing for people to think that
this was like a good outcome for us to
have what's your main message on your
heart right now to people in this time
i would keep i would pay people
i would look at the things just like i
said about number one find out what and
who you need to cut
same thing i would tell a household what
and who do you need to cut from your
life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it
yeah financial is there people in your
life that you could afford to have in
january and you can't afford to have
many more
you got to cut them you got to boss up
right now you got to be you got to do
the tough thing if you want to take care
of your tribe your group your family
you have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you should just be yourself
right i mean i i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm quite grumpy